hey guys I'm with former world champion
human rights activist Gary Kasparov this
has been a big couple weeks for chats
first of all how do you feel about how
the London chess classic finished off
well it's very exciting yeah it's just
shows again that classical chess is not
dead yeah it could be tons of excitement
it all depends on players mood and
they're all day not so many the size of
games here but we can hardly complain
about lack of the fighting spirit many
missing chances many mistakes but you
know mistakes is also always part of a
good show yes and what do you think
about this climactic game between
research and Carlson okay everything
happened in the last round so it seems
that you know Greece you've made three
mistakes in the row missing chances to
win music a fourth drawer and then
probably still a chance to save the game
but you know that scars from was taking
his chance you know making very risky
move so I wouldn't put my kunin a six a
knight on d5 but okay at the end of the
day it paid off and what are your
predictions tonight oh it's a sometimes
you know we know just its following the
rules creates some kind of a confusion
because now by the rules Magnus has by
that's just and he's waiting for for
unease and and maxim to to play
tie-break and the winner should
challenge magnus for the title in this
tournament and then this we can face a
funny situation that if of a share wins
first match against a niche and any
place magnums and he wins this match he
has to play again for 22 to break a tie
break break a tie for four total grand
prix everything happens when you have
the first event and you're just you know
you you can you can predict all the
situation so no matter how much time you
spent you know calculating all possible
scenarios well we know that you know
life is always tricky than we think
that's right and who do you think has
the stamina for that well I guess Magnus
cuz he had to buy right it has about yes
obviously you know he's
is a big favorite because you know they
have to play to rapid chess games I mean
I hope organizers would you know we'll
show some respect for the players and
we'll move second match for tomorrow
because it's it's it's very very
difficult for players you know just to
have two games now and then to play
almost in the middle of the night so
again just and they will preserve you
know more excitement and to you know
keep the intrigue life for 24 more hours
I'm totally not sure if it's possible
but i'm sure they definitely respect to
the players regardless um and there's
been a lot going on chess politics last
couple weeks tell us a little bit about
your thoughts on alumina i don't think
it's as to do was chess politics you
know it's probably know many chess
players they just said Allah paranoid
about what's happening now just kingdom
while you know Chris on Gina did what he
has been doing for many years you know
surrogate as the KGB and void in this
and as of the hot spot indeed
geo-political map and this time he was
caught by by us authorities by
facilitating the oil trade between
Bashar al-assad's regime and Isis and I
don't think anybody in the Treasury
Department or other organizations of the
United States and it will follow
aluminum they paid any real attention to
the fact that is also it was his a
president of the other Chess Federation
it's it will have disastrous consequence
for our game because you know when when
such in the bad story becomes public you
know I don't think sponsors will ever
you know touch the game there were I
don't think many of them you know had
had this intention before but aren't you
unhappy about this in a way I mean it
was inevitable right I think was
inevitable I've been saying about it for
years and it seems to me that the world
of chess always turned a blonde I
thinking that you know illusion was so
lucky that he could get away with this
anytime he did it and now it's again it
damages the reputation of our game
further but you know we didn't see many
corporate sponsors you know lining up
for feed events so now
you know probably will be even even even
less possible options to sort to make
this they make our great game so a
mainstream pastime you really feel that
negatively about it but I mean you're so
involved with a grand chest or I mean
don't you see some hope as well oh you
asked me what feed them this is this is
a ball chest politics and I told you
that it was nothing that was just
politics so I'm very happy that the gran
gran chester was a success and hopefully
next year will be you know will be even
better year because they it will be
based already on the experience
accumulated in israel these three
tournaments and again it's a sweet we
have a great game you know it's and this
game you know will survive in a wizard
of janelle for with whoever but still
every game even the greatest game and in
this planet are requiring a proper
organizational management so
grandchester probably will compensate
for some of the failures I'll feed it
but unfortunately in early several
tournament organizers who are who are
wishing well for the game of chess and
we're ready to to create a professional
infrastructure they cannot replace sort
of the the global chat system that is
still responsibility of the
International Chess Federation so the
rankings are very tight on the grand
test or to see you guys qualified next
year was there any player that you kind
of wish it involved this year who didn't
make the cut look you know I hope that
everybody who can qualify will make it
next year so i wonder if-if Cromley
changes his mind and will play because
he definitely makes it the whole idea of
a Grunch store is a step to be impartial
it's not about you know selecting
players because organizers like him or
not so you can have wild card but to be
to be part of the of the grand tool for
three events you you have to i mean you
have to deserve it you have to earn it
and the rating system is quite objective
it's it's a long it it tells us you know
who who can beat in or who will be out
so we'll see you know what what happens
next time but
I think unlike unless I'm I'm totally
mistaken I don't believe there would be
significant changes so because the last
year i miss 2015 made very little
changes in the india / ranking of top 10
players Wesley might make it this year
what yes maybe Wesley I can make it
maybe Dalaran from China so I don't know
the average but it's just it'sit's we
might see some change so i would say
maybe one or two players in air will
will will show up do put new faces
marianna if we're talking about Wesley
saw Dean Lorenzo we're talking about you
know young players you know fresh blood
so that's always good so to see more
young players joining the circle was
there anything that surprised you about
this grandchester oh yo yeah i think is
this is Magnus overall performance was
quite a lousy one so it's it's okay he
was lucky at the end of this torment but
let's not forget he made fifty percent I
mean these overall scores fifty percent
in in 27 games ironically giver has plus
five so that's and he is now to play the
[ __ ] you actually challenge beckons so
it's again rules are the rules but I
think that's it's it's this this grant
or actually demonstrated Magnus
advantage over other players he's not as
big as well thought before and I'm
hopefully it will give him another just
to know it's an extra extra reason
psychological reason to work harder and
just to show show is best for next year
absolutely well thank you very much we
had Garry Kasparov on his thoughts on
the grand Chester and beyond back to you
guys in the studio as we get excited for
this playoff listen Lucy